reconciliation
reconciliation and integration is a
pathway towards wholeness
pathway towards
mental health
we're all after reconciliation we're all
after
positive catharsis right the place in
which thesis and antithesis is resolved
by synthesis
the place beyond duality a place of
wholeness of integration
integration of the shadow integration of
the light
where where our disjointment comes back
into alignment
and that's what we're all looking for
we're all
we're all desiring
of this experience of this threshold
crossing of this baptism that finally
will make us whole
and
you know life throws you punches and
disjointment follows the the fractures
of trauma are such that we experience a
schism
and we become
frightened even of ourselves we're no
longer safe in our own bodies and what
this does is it casts a shadow upon our
experience of the world we bring this
trauma to the doorstep of every moment
and so we become
afraid the world becomes hostile and
this this dark cloud of trauma that kind
of colors our windshield becomes our
interpretive framework it becomes our
lens of perception and as chris lethar
be wrote we see through our lenses and
we see with our lenses but we don't see
the lenses themselves and so that scary
world we're seeing through our lenses is
being shaped and informed and colored by
that lens but we don't realize that
anymore we've come to believe that the
lens is reality that the map is the
territory but this corrupted lens and
this corrupted map that's been that's
been severed and disjointed that's
experienced the schism of trauma the
rape the transgression the violation
that has brought us into disjoint and
dis congruence this is now coloring our
world the body keeps the score we bring
this gnawing anxiety and
self-consciousness with us to the
doorstep of every moment it's temporal
dislocation that's what david david
lanson calls it and in this temporal
dislocation
we we
we over determine the present moment we
misread the present moment and so we're
walking on eggshells unnecessarily a
victim of our own self-defeating
projections and we need to break through
this we need to break past this to come
back into wholeness and so that map of
the world that lens of perception has to
die we have to have an experience that
is akin to inverse ptsd right an
experience that is as intense as the
trauma was but it's inverse and so what
that does is it bumps us up a level and
now we can see the lenses that we see
through and with we can actually see the
lenses themselves and once we see the
lenses we can dispense with those lenses
and that means we become twice born and
now we meet the world not with fear
perhaps but with curiosity and grace and
equanimity something has shifted from
the inside out and then everything
changes right and so that's what we're
all after that kind of healing that kind
of reconciling from disjoint coming into
congruence or coming into integrity or
coming into acceptance and coming into
wholeness we need to integrate all of us
and come back into that place we need to
reconcile we need positive catharsis
and and my whole life is it is about
that journey right we're all on the eat
pray love journey you know the irony is
that these videos surf serve to me as
evidentiary
you know as evidentiary
footage you know that that that i'm
trying to leave paper trails i'm trying
to map out the terrain right i'm trying
i'm trying to
i'm trying to to see if i can heal
and if i can come back into wholeness
and if i can reconcile and if i can do
it you can do it if we can do it well
hey man then
then
well then we stand a chance at
we stand a chance of uh
yeah of walking amongst gods
of
returning to the garden of eden
uh
of
experiencing moment by moment the
miracle of naked existence
to marvel
to awe
to feel to know
and that's what we want
that's what we want
that feeling
that feeling at the end of the greatest
film you've ever seen
and
it's the end of the movie
[Music]
but everything is better now
and everything is going to be okay
i think that's a very powerful thing
it's very powerful
[Music]
that's called positive catharsis
[Music]
i'm not gonna cry but i'm close
but i think that's what everybody's
everybody's after
how about this
[Music]
um
[Music]
the realization in the end
is that paradise
it's not a place you go
but a way you feel for a moment in your
life when you're a part of something
when you find that moment
it lasts forever
it's just like so beautiful and then the
photograph appears and it says parallel
universe and her signature that shows
proof
that this was once real that we were
once whole
[Music]
this really did happen we really did
meet
bittersweet happy sad
beautiful
so friends yes
i hope we all find that
i think we all are deserving of that
those moments
that
connection magic
romance freedom